99 of americans have at least one
television in their home
could you survive without a television
hey everyone
welcome to yessi tv where you can find
weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life
this week's video is a bit similar to
last week's video on why i do not have
social media
and we're going to be talking about why
i do not own a television
so i'm going to share with you my six
reasons for why we tossed ours in the
first place
and if you stick to the end i will share
with you my three tips for how you can
ditch yours for good
reason number one conversation killer
for most people their days are spent
very busy shuffling between work
school sports daily to-do's take out the
trash
we didn't want our precious family time
to be spent sitting in front of a screen
each person in their own world not
really talking to one another
when we first decided to get rid of our
tv i remember being worried
about how we were gonna host friends and
family members
and whether or not they were gonna be
bored or we were gonna have things to do
or to talk about
then i remembered a time when i visited
a friend and we spent three hours just
talking and to her husband's surprised
face when he asked
you didn't go anywhere you didn't do
anything
but talk we laughed that day as we told
him
yeah we talked
being able to enjoy each other's company
and talk about our lives
goals and ideas became a priority for my
husband and i
and having a television only became a
barrier
reason number two negativity
the average child will watch 8 000
murders before completing elementary
school
and by the age of 18 the average adult
will have watched
200 000 acts of violence
tell me what your thoughts are i want to
know do you think that constantly seeing
acts of violence and crime
can change your perspective of the world
at least for me personally i know that
watching things like the news
only brings up feelings of me of anger
worry
and anxiety as i see all of the things
that are going wrong in the world
after all television is made to make
money and happy stories with happy
endings and no action
does not make money so i ditched the big
screen of negativity
the third reason why we decided to ditch
the tv is because it did not in line
with our values
not to make this long i will only give
you one example but we
highly value respect for our elders and
for our parents
when i was a child if i even so much as
raised my voice at my parents
i was whooped no i'm not talking about
whether or not you should whoop your
children
but what i mean is at a young age it was
very much ingrained in me from my
parents that i was to respect my elders
and to respect my parents
and i know from watching children's
shows things like disney channel
often show children that the dad is the
dumb person
and that they can talk back to their
parents and this is a funny thing and
it's a cool thing and that is not
something that we want to teach our
children
and most cartoons today are not as clean
humored and family oriented as they were
at least when i was a child at least for
us
most of what is on tv does not reflect
the kinds of characteristics that we
want in our children
and the value of respect is only one
example
reason number four we fall prey to
advertising
by the age of 65 the average american
will have seen
two million commercials did you ever sit
through a commercial and all of a sudden
realize that you need that dyson vacuum
cleaner
or suddenly feel hungry after seeing a
commercial of a juicy cheeseburger
we are constantly being told that we
need more that we need that new necklace
that we need that new weight loss plan
that avocado slicer or that hot dog
slicer
ooh hot dog slicer that's kind of cute
how much is that
reason number five is health research
has shown
time and time again that a positive
mindset can actually improve your
overall health and your lifespan as well
and this makes sense because as i've
mentioned in previous videos
stress triggers inflammation which
triggers disease
so on one side not having a television
can help me be healthier as a person
because by removing the negative
influences from television
i am increasing my positive mindset and
therefore
being able to be happier as a person and
healthier
but on the other side i can also be
healthier
physically as well americans are
becoming increasingly more sedentary in
their lifestyle
a research study reported on ergonomic
trends reported that people who sit for
six hours or more and have a sedentary
lifestyle
have a 71 higher mortality rate
71 those stats were scary to me but the
truth is that we could all use a little
bit more movement and if we're sitting
in front of a screen
we're not getting movement now when i
get bored i actually get up and do
something
okay sometimes it's sitting and reading
a book but most of the time i get up i
play with my daughter i go for a walk
or i start a project or a craft that i
forgotten about or that i had
procrastinated
and lastly reason number six
productivity and procrastination
there's only 24 hours in a day so of
course the more time you spend doing one
activity
the less time you have doing another
according to this bar graph from the
american bureau of labor statistics
most americans spend at least two hours
a day watching television
this fluctuates based on age employment
status and other factors
but you get the picture if you have two
hours to spend on watching television
that's two hours that you could have
spent doing other things
maybe you have a project that you've
been putting off maybe you could use a
little more sleep
more time with your family or more time
to work on skills to improve yourself
and your career not having a television
can free
so much of your time so that you can
spend it to making your life better
now that i've shared with you my six
reasons for why we just the tv
i can share with you my three tips for
how you can say bye bye to the black
screen
but first did you know the average
american has at least two televisions in
their home
how many do you have let me know in the
comments
my tip number one is if you are not
quite ready to part ways with your tv
and it's still a huge part of your life
ease into it
adopt a household rule when tv and
electronics are not allowed at specific
times
for us for example this is bedtime for
kiddos
and meal times if someone calls us or
messages us
during bedtime for the kiddos or while
we're eating dinner we will not answer
the phone until
after we're finished and for my husband
and i it actually became
very important that we never answer the
phone during meal times
even if the kids are not around because
it's important to us that we keep
dating even after being married because
life gets busy and you go your separate
ways
and you lose sight of one another and
for us it was a huge priority to let our
kids know that we value them enough to
dedicate time specifically to them
tip number two if you've moved past the
reluctant stage and you're ready to toss
it
but you worry that you might regret it
unplug it and put it in an area that's
hard for you to reach
for me i did this for actually about two
weeks before we actually said let's just
do it
we unplugged it and we moved it into the
attic not only did this make it harder
for us to actually go get it plug it in
if we wanted to watch something
but for us to have it for two weeks put
away we could realize
oh you know what this isn't so bad we
are living a pretty normal life without
it and we can deal without it
and tip number three if you've already
done number two now fill the void with
something that brings you
joy on our tv stand we placed an oil
painting that my husband made of the
sunset on our first date
when i missed the tv the first few days
this made me happy and it made me
remember
why we did it in the first place you can
use family photos
board games artwork whatever brings you
joy and whatever reminds you what's most
valuable to you
and what's most important to you in your
life and for sticking to the end my
bonus tip for you is don't see this as a
loss but as a gain
you're not losing a television you're
gaining quality time with the ones you
love
meaningful relationships and the
opportunity to work on improving
yourself as a person
guys our time is ticking and we'll run
out someday
what do you want to do and accomplish in
your life and who and what matters most
to you
your time is precious so use it wisely
that's it for today guys if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
and subscribe so that you won't miss out
on my weekly videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one